this is what a disease-free future looks
like
many people live in BIO alive habitats
built from fungus and bacteria this
constant exposure to Nature boosts the
immune system from birth people use
high-tech home scanners to analyze the
DNA of microbes living in their guts
armed with this Data Doctors
intentionally infect patients with
combinations of good bacteria to keep
the bad ones in check preventing disease
before it starts by using advanced
technology to adjust the microbes in
everyone's body modern diseases are
mostly a thing of the past
it all of a sudden hits you like the
inside of you right now
today scientists are blazing a trail to
this very future they're actually more
micro than your human I want to know
what breakthroughs are being made by
augmenting our bodies will have a
fundamental impact on modern day plagues
that will Forge the future too to me
that was like whoa a disease-free world
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
y I decided to become a neuroscientist
because my nan and several great aunts
developed Alzheimer's disease this loss
has made me determined to find a cure by
any means
I'm fascinated by Recent research that
links diseases of the brain to microbes
in our bodies and I think this is an
Avenue that is just coming into its own
in terms of research
microbes are tiny living things smaller
than the eye can see inside the body
microbes like bacteria parasites and
viruses can cause any number of
infectious diseases
so what would happen if we just
eradicated all of the body's nasty
microorganisms
what would the health of society look
like
to answer that I want to understand how
microorganisms cause disease in the
first place
so I've come to Perth Australia to meet
Dr Barry Marshall
Barry's groundbreaking research turned
the world's understanding of stomach
cancer on its head and warn him the
Nobel Prize in medicine
Barry is a complete science Legend
today barriers hunting a nasty microbe
called helicobacter this this bacteria
infects the guts of animals and makes
them sick there are about 30 different
kinds of helicobacter so one of the
things I'm planning to do today is go
around get some animal scat so most of
it's kangaroo I'm looking forward to
seeing the whole process
I've never seen a kangaroo I don't think
[Music]
Barry is trying to figure out where
helicobacter came from by searching for
it in a wide range of animals
did you see those big grassy areas over
there that's where the kangaroos might
be hanging out
I've seen one
well I think I can see one
it looks like it's good enough
by analyzing kangaroo feces Barry can
get a snapshot of the microorganisms
living inside these kangaroos guts you
can get all the different kinds of
bacteria that will extract the DNA and
just put all the DNA through the
computer
it was the hunt for helicobacter that
led Barry and his colleague Robin Warren
to overturn what they thought might be a
myth
namely the widely held belief in the
medical community that stomach ulcers
were caused by stress
I did have patients who had ulcers and
it annoyed me that they seem to be
normal people but when you couldn't find
the cause of their Elsa you'd always the
medical books would blame it on stress
anyway so all these people just seem to
be normal when they looked at Patients
stomach ulcers under the microscope what
they found was astonishing these
bacteria were unusual they're curved
bacteria the Infectious agent at work
was helicobacter pylori
each pylori for short is a variation of
helicobacter that infects humans
the presence of this microbe in the
human stomach upended Decades of medical
understanding
all of the textbooks said that nothing
can grow in our stomach you know it's a
sterile environment for these types of
bacteria but your findings proved
otherwise so that became our research
project how could bacteria live in the
stomach when the so much acid
we knew these bacteria were really only
human bacteria so we had to find a human
volunteer who could take the bacteria
and maybe get an ulcer so
that these bacteria could in fact a
healthy stomach at all costs So
eventually I did a self-experiment we
decided that I was going to drink the
bacteria which I did
so we grew the bacteria up in meat broth
like beef soup if you like and I drank
it down and then I was having an
endoscopy to see if they had colonized
my stomach
and after 10 days
the bacteria were there the infection
was taking hold and they were damaging
the lining of the stomach Barbie was
probably the first person to be happy
with this diagnosis I didn't have any
evidence until I did that
self-experiment Barry's experiment was a
success
but how can H pylori thrive in the
stomach's extreme conditions we found
out that helicobacteria unique they make
ammonia and they neutralize the
hydrochloric acid so they can survive
nothing else can once established in the
stomach these invasive bacteria lead to
ulcers
and if allowed to Fester they can cause
cancer
the question became how could these
killer microbes be stopped it's always
excited about the fact that potentially
you could cure something if it's caused
by bacteria it turned out that
antibiotics can kill H pylori and cure
the ulcers in a matter of weeks
long before the discovery of microbes
scientists had no idea of the role
microscopic germs played in human health
but in the 19th century French scientist
Louis Pasteur developed germ Theory
which postulated that microorganisms
cause infectious disease and British
surgeon Joseph Lister found a way to
prevent germs from infecting his
patients by using antiseptics to
sterilize his surgical equipment and
clean wounds
but the big breakthrough happened in
1928 when Scottish physician Alexander
Fleming accidentally discovered
penicillin
penicillin was an immediate cure role
for scarlet fever meningitis and even
pneumonia this medication launched the
modern era of antibiotics
great kindness to be able to tell people
no it's not stress take some antibiotics
and you'll be cured
today ulcers are no longer a chronic
illness for many and in the U.S cases of
stomach cancer have decreased almost
every year like most people I like to
prove other people are wrong I didn't
realize it was going to take 23 years
before people really believed it and
accepted it by eradicating the microbes
that cause stomach ulcers and cancer
Barry's research is forging a
disease-free future before infections
even start
detect foreign agents when people enter
the home the scanner sweeps the entire
body for harmful microbes if detected a
home health robot immediately dispenses
the appropriate medication most people
no longer suffer from infectious disease
and doctors visits are mostly a thing of
the past
[Music]
a disease-free future like this sounds
very appealing
so what would happen if we just
eradicated all microbes
to find out I first want to know exactly
what functions they serve so I've come
to Amsterdam to speak with biologists
and head of the micropia museum Jasper
Becks he has some sobering information
about the microbes role in the human
body there's about 10 times more
microbes in and on your body than you
have body cells so you're actually more
micro than you're human that is quite a
scary thought so I'm basically just a
carrier for the micro
micropia developed a technology to help
visualize this unseen Universe this is
where you can visit your own microbes
this is you hey you're being scanned
we're gonna see who has the most
microbes so every dot that you see here
is a microbe a total of a hundred
thousand billion of them 99 of all those
trillions of microbes live in your
intestines these are all digital dots of
course but we also have them alive
The Staggering number of microbes on
display makes my skin crawl
but there's an odd sense of beauty to
behold
when you say these under the microscope
moving it all of a sudden hits you like
there inside you right now that is crazy
[Music]
the first person to accidentally see
these tiny organisms was Anthony vanley
uvenhook in the 17th century
he was a draper in order to test the
quality of the cotton and of the threats
he decided to build his own magnifying
lenses and this is what he made and he
was able to reach a magnification of 250
times
by looking at everything from water to
the plaque on his teeth he found the
world teeming with all kinds of strange
microscopic creatures
that made him the first scientist so to
speak to discover the invisible world of
microbes but in fact these creatures
have been with us all along
single-celled bacteria evolved three and
a half billion years ago they are the
oldest life forms on Earth on mass these
microbes exhaled oxygen which eventually
formed our modern day atmosphere and
created an ecosystem that changed the
face of the entire planet
scientists believe our oxygenated
ecosystem led to the evolution of
multicellular life forms at least 600
million years ago and this in turn led
to the evolution of even more complex
creatures including us humans
in this light microbes are the most
fundamental part of Being Human they
digest your Foods they produce all kinds
of different vitamins and hormones so
microbes are essential to our way of
life scientists call this vast
collection of microbes living in us and
on us the human microbiome in essence
your your walking ecosystem that's
honestly mind-blowing each body is a
unique walking ecosystem but how exactly
do these trillions of microbes
contribute to a person's well-being and
how do we get our individual microbiome
in the first place
to find out I've come to Rutgers
University to meet biologist Dr Maria
Gloria dominguez-bello
he's researching each person's Dynamic
relationship with their own individual
microbiome
microbes are part of Earth if we didn't
have them we wouldn't be healthy we are
now understanding that we didn't evolve
alone
every animal and plant on Earth evolve
with bacteria in particular like a coral
reef or a rainforest the microbiome is
an ecosystem unto itself when you have
an ecosystem that is perturbed the first
question an ecologists ask is can you
restore the ecosystem
Gloria's understanding of the microbiome
started in of all places the Amazon
jungle where she saw firsthand how human
microbial ecosystems can quickly change
I've been working in the Amazon for the
last 30 years since I was a student
amerindians have been living there
pretty isolated for the last 20 000
years and I was very interested in
understanding the microbiome of
traditional peoples
skin mouth and fecal samples she
measured the impact that external
environments in which people lived had
on their internal ecosystems
Gloria found that those living in the
Amazonian jungle have a significantly
higher diversity in their microbes as
City dwellers living in industrialized
countries but when an individual from
the remote Amazon moved to the city they
quickly lost their microbial diversity
this leads to a startling conclusion
so that work has shown us that
urbanization depletes and destroys the
diversity of the microbiome
and in the gut diversity is good we know
that because diseases decrease diversity
and when you decrease diversity you
cause disease there is a strong
association between High diversity in
the gut microbiome and health
knowing how vital microbiome diversity
is in fighting disease
Gloria is investigating how humans
acquire microbes in the first place here
we go
and how do babies originally acquire
their microbes inside their uterus the
baby is not being exposed to microbes
but once mom breaks water the baby comes
in contact with the birth canal which is
loaded with massive amount of bacteria
it turns out the acquisition of microbes
starts when a child is born by the time
the baby is out the baby is heavily
colonized so it's a microbial baptism
then there is a skin to skin contact
that's the secondary exposure then the
mouth of the mother pissing is a another
exposure the environment of that baby is
heavily maternal and Mom is a main
source of bacteria
first set of bacteria start the process
of immune education
the immune system will recognize the
good bacteria don't attack but modern
medicine is changing the immunity
education that comes from this microbial
baptism the rate of cesarean bat is
increasing since 1990 C-sections have
more than tripled going from around 6 to
21 of all births globally
C-sections successfully take the baby
out but without passing through the
birth canal this means that C-section
babies are born from a sterile uterus
into the air of an operating room and
Gloria has discovered that this may
increase the risk of many diseases
C-section has been associated in humans
with increased risk of their modern
diseases for example an increased risk
of asthma type 1 diabetes allergies and
obesity starting at Birth the first
three years of life are critical in
establishing a healthy diversity of
microbes
[Music]
foreign
I think it's just fascinating that many
new parents are probably quite unaware
that the first few years of life are so
important for the baby's development of
their microbiome
not only that Gloria's research is
revealing that the overuse of
antibiotics to eradicate harmful
microbes early in life is leading to a
bigger problem than we ever realized we
have impacted every step of development
the average baby receives 2.7 doses of
antibiotics in the first year of life we
have been so successful controlling
infectious diseases but what we didn't
know was the collateral damage that was
caused to our microbiome we have
increased the risk of our kids to live
lives with chronic diseases we evolved
with this biology we cannot ignore it
because if we do we are screwing the
health of our future Generations while
helpful in many ways sterilization of
modern day practices like C-sections and
antibiotics could actually be harming on
microbiomes May making us more
susceptible to disease but we can't just
get rid of modern medicine altogether
antibiotics and C-sections still save
millions of lives so what's the right
approach
Gloria has invited me to her home to
meet her husband Dr Martin Blazer
hi Julie I lovely to meet you Martin is
a microbiologist who also researches the
microbiome
when it comes to using antibiotics both
Gloria and Martin believe we need a
better balance
by and large we have overestimated the
value of antibiotics we're giving
antibiotics like water the big Dogma is
it might not help you but it won't hurt
but what if it does hurt there's more
and more evidence we're losing microbial
diversity it's just going down Martin
and Gloria want to prevent the further
loss of diversity in all microbiomes
we've overdone it now we have to find a
more moderate approach and and
ultimately if we find a more modern
approach then maybe we can stop the
decline in diversity but how do we get
it back that's going to require
restoration one intriguing candidate for
microbial restoration is the H pylori
bacteria the same one the Barry Marshall
infected himself with most doctors in
the world are trying to get rid of
helicobacteria on the idea that it's a
bad guy and it is but since then we've
been finding all kinds of good things
that the bacteria does
it turns out that some microbes are
double agents and can be both bad and
good for the body what are the good
things you found out about H pylori well
we found that people who don't have
helicobacter have more disease than
their esophagus and we also found that
children who don't have helicobacter
have more asthma and that's really big
because asthma is going up helicobacter
is going down we think that they're left
David's being with Humanity for
Millennia today only five percent of
children in the US have the H pylori
bacteria
so if H pylori can cause stomach cancer
but eliminating air increases rates of
asthma what should we choose it turns
out we may not have to I predict that
we'll be giving helicobacter pulmonary
back to children
so that we can protect them against
things like asthma but we might want to
eradicate it when they're 40 years old
so that they won't get stomach cancer we
have to treat these bugs differently in
childhood and once you are an adult this
Revelation shows how we could begin to
get the balance right by treating the
microbiome differently at different
stages in a person's life Gloria and
Martin's Dynamic approach could be the
key to eliminating modern diseases
in the future nearly every baby is born
naturally at home when C-sections are
needed babies are bathed and infected
with microbes taken from the mother's
birth canal from childhood everyone
receives personalized doses of healthy
microbes as regularly as vaccines only
prescribed in severe cases the overuse
of antibiotics has plummeted
if the key to a disease-free future lies
in managing the balance of good and bad
microbes then what we put into our
bodies will have a huge impact on the
microbiome to better understand how the
body's microbes work as a whole I've
come to San Diego to meet Dr Rob Knight
he's looking for ways to create a better
balance in individuals microbiomes by
sequencing their DNA
based on numbers alone this is a very
daunting task you have about twenty
thousand or so unique genes and you're a
human genome but you have millions of
genes in your microbiome and all of
those microbial genes we're just finding
out about how they make us who we are
that is incredible that we call
ourselves human but maybe we're not so
Human After All
Rob's Quest is an ambitious undertaking
through the American gut project he
co-founded he's crowdsourcing and
analyzing stool samples from across the
planet and because it's an open source
project he'll ultimately share the
conclusions of this big data with
everyone for now by sequencing microbial
DNA from a wide array of people Rob's
pioneering work is diving deeper into
the human microbiome than ever before
especially in how our microbes respond
to food
in tandem with this Rob's team is also
sequencing the DNA of the microbes that
colonize the foods we eat to analyze and
compare its impact on microbes in the
human body so what did you collect from
the Garden today so we got another set
of fruit and vegetable samples so
Rosemary tomato eggplant we got today
great by understanding the microbial big
picture Rob has discovered something
surprising one of the most fascinating
and most unexpected things was the
particular ways that diet impacts the
microbiome categories that people think
are going to make a huge difference like
are you an omnivore are you a vegan are
you on the paleo diet that kind of thing
it has almost no bearing on your
microbiome results
This research is contradicting
prevailing wisdom it turns out what does
affect the health of our gut microbiome
is much more basic and even achievable
for most of us the things that do matter
turn out to be things like how many
different species of plants you ate in
the last couple of weeks things like do
you eat a lot of salty snacks or sugary
snacks wow that is really interesting
work Rob's research is showing that
eating at least 30 different types of
plants per week leads to a more diverse
gut microbiome and this matters because
this helps create a better balance of
both the beneficial and harmful microbes
that are in everyone
this microbial diversity dramatically
increases the body's well-being
so eat your veggies
for everyone's microbiome is not alike
like a fingerprint your gut microbiome
is unique and responds differently than
others it even plays a role in how
individuals respond to prescription
drugs
one of the major things that we and
others are trying to find out at the
moment is how do you know what
medications are going to work it turns
out that the microbiome explains a lot
of that individual variability
that's because got microbes play a role
in how medications are metabolized in
the body an individual's microbiome can
impact the effectiveness of drugs for
Parkinson's high cholesterol and many
other conditions
a better understanding of this complex
relationship could lead to Major
breakthroughs in healthcare muscles
already being exploited right now for
cancer drugs and so that's a very
exciting Frontier
[Music]
I want to see if there are measures I
can take to achieve a better microbial
balance today
so I'm conjuncting a little experiment
of my own with a sample kit from the
American gut project
which contains tubes and swabs and some
gloves so I think we can all imagine
exactly what this is for taking samples
of
I'm eating junk food for three days and
then a wide range of vegetables for
three days
and I'll be taking two samples after the
healthy foods and after the unhealthy
food I think is my microbiome has been
altered oh I'm gonna be sick that is
horrible
I'm bringing these samples to Dr Jack
Gilbert
other co-founder of the American got
project
his team is using this research to tease
out the body's specific relationship
between our microbiome and the
development of disease
what have you brought us well this is a
little bit mortifying and I've brought
you some samples from a small experiment
that I decided to conduct myself yeah I
want to see if the health of my
microbiome improves in the short term do
you think that change could be seen in
three days it's a little short yeah
but it's enough to see some changes
starting to occur
while the samples are processed Jack
walks me through the complex
relationship between our microbes food
and disease
what we found was if you had a stable
microbiome that was say promoting
obesity I.E a microbiome that made you
fat by producing chemicals which changed
your relationship to food it would take
almost a year on a new diet to eradicate
those microbes and change it to one that
doesn't promote weight gain that's the
problem with diets nobody stays on them
for an entire year
also contributing to the chronic disease
of obesity a modern day diet of Highly
processed foods can cause the microbiome
to become imbalanced too much sugar too
much saturated fat is changing the types
of bacteria which live inside us
to test the relationship between the
microbiome and weight researchers took
fecal samples from obese mice and
transferred these samples into the guts
of lean germ-free mice incredibly this
transfer changed the microbiome of the
lean mice
after the microbial transplant the lean
mice gained weight and became obese it
turns out that gut bacteria play a big
role in regulating the body's overall
metabolism
Jack police microbiomes adjusted for
poor diets have a similar negative
effect on humans leading to any number
of debilitating diseases and we think
that is having an impact upon things
like diabetes and obesity maybe even
depression and anxiety similar
microbiome transplant studies with mice
suggest there is also a connection
between the microbes in our guts and
Alzheimer's I am really interested in
the link between you've got microbiome
and Alzheimer's disease you have a
family history of Alzheimer's I do yes
that's my motivation for doing a PhD in
the first place so I have the genetic
precursors as well from the wonderful
gifts my brother gave me yes probably
mine too exactly there's a number of
different ways the microbes in your gut
can affect what goes under your brain
one pathway is the vagus nerve this long
nerve connects the intestines with the
brain creating a two-way channel of
communication research suggests that
stress signals from the brain may cause
gastrointestinal distress while signals
from the gut May alter moods the brain
and gut are also connected by the body's
immune system and this is very relevant
for Alzheimer's and Parkinson's is the
microbes in your gut change how your
immune system works they can cause
inflammation that spreads throughout the
body and then can change how the brain
is receiving information and how the
brain is receiving chemicals
Jack's research suggests that by
eliminating inflammation-causing
microbes in the intestines through
medication or dietary changes we might
prevent Alzheimer's disease
that is a phenomenal change in
understanding
of late life diseases patients often
have changes in their brain years before
you see any symptoms
do you think we could see an almost
microbiome signature of these changes
and then jump in with some early
preventative measures I think that is
absolutely possible Right In combination
with looking in your blood and seeing if
there are biomarkers of the disease we
could also look in your stool and look
at the types of microbes which would
cause the disease to start progressing
so we may be able to transform our
ability to predict it early in the
future Jack is developing a new
technology that will allow people to
track biomarkers in their gut
microbiomes at home this is a a mock-up
that we're using very nice but we've
developed a toilet seat literally just
this part of the toilet that allows for
the collection in an automated way of
stool yeah and then provide you with
updated regular information about the
microbes and their functions that are
present there or we might be able to
provide you with an update on what kind
of foods you should eat then we may be
able to prevent disease from developing
in the first place by changing what
microbes are present in your gut that
would be a phenomenal improvement in our
understanding of human health as for my
short experiment the fried and fatty
junk food had a negative impact on the
balance of my microbiome Jack recommends
sticking with healthier eating and
consuming more fiber by analyzing
optimizing and managing our own
microbiomes we could create a future
where diseases are kept at Bay
in the future many people perform health
checks by profiling their microbiomes at
home in real time toothbrushes sequence
the DNA of billions of microbes in the
digestive tract the data is networked
with appliances allowing individuals to
receive automatic daily food deliveries
that are personalized for Optimal Health
this data also syncs with medication
dispensers which fine-tune prescriptions
to diversify the microbiome and boost
the immune system
since Studies have shown that microbiome
transplants can be used to transfer
diseases from one animal to another I
wonder if this same technique could be
used to cure disease as well I'm outside
Boston to meet Carolyn Edelson her open
biome organization is combating a
notorious bacteria C difficile or C diff
Ethan biome is helping fight this
life-threatening gut infection with a
radical treatment human fecal
transplants
C diff or C difficile is the most common
hospital card infection in the U.S
actually who is at risk of Contracting
it oftentimes what happens is someone
will go into a hospital or a long-term
care facility they'll go on antibiotics
and they'll acquire a seed of infection
what happens when you go on antibiotics
is a lot of the microbes that are
normally presenting or got get wiped out
and we've had that competition CDF is
able to to spread and to start producing
the toxin that makes you sick cetif is
really difficult to kill and to get rid
of because it makes little spores these
toxic spores are seed death's most
ruthless weapon against the body because
of this it's pretty easy for patients to
be colonized by C diff
infects a half a million Americans every
year with a staggering mortality rate as
high as 30 percent but a novel solution
has been developed to change the gut's
ecosystem and restore and rebalance the
gut microbiome of those infected most of
the time CDF can be treated with a fecal
transplant so you take a sample of stool
from a healthy person and in that stool
is trillions of bacteria that live
inside our guts and what we're doing is
transferring that community of bacteria
into the colon of the patient to
out-compete the pathogen similar
approaches were pioneered by the Chinese
in the 4th century when they prescribed
yellow soup made with fecal matter to
treat colon diseases by rebalancing and
rediversifying the gut microbiome the
return of beneficial bacteria should
keep the C diff infection in check
associate director of biomanufacturing
the Lassie de la Sachi is going to show
me how they make this Cutting Edge
science a reality
here at first base mask a couple pairs
of gloves lab coat and shoe covers and
why do we have to wear all of this yeah
I need to make sure that as humans we're
not contaminating the product that's
going into an already compromised
patient I mean I'm looking fantastic so
good feeling great looking great ready
to go perfect
awesome this is essentially the first
step this is where they'll do a visual
assessment of the sample and what are
the assessment criteria for a piece of
clue like what what is a good piece
so there's a visual assessment for color
that's also assessed for size there's
also a scale that we create the the
stool on it's going to give you
viscosity uh texture hardness I never
thought I'd say I'm looking forward to
seeing a piece of poo yeah but here we
go I'm excited
so this is the actual uh stool that's
going to be processed what would you say
this one is we determined that it would
be a four a Bristol four essentially
that's kind of known as like the perfect
texture for a stool sample to come in
initial continue processing I feel like
it's really interesting though like you
guys are obviously quite immune to it
baby because you work with this every
day for me that was like whoa
once the microbial diversity of the
stool samples are determined to be
sufficient they are stored in giant
freezers
oh wow there are a lot
yeah freezes what's in the freezer frame
it's amazing
these remedies are stored at minus 80
Celsius to keep the healthy bacteria
viable before shipping to Hospitals and
Clinics
so they're mixed with a saline and
glycerol solution
this is a fecal microbiota preparation
that will be delivered by colonoscopy so
this is the most common treatment format
that we make and this is what it looks
like
to date open biome has shipped over 50
000 fecal transplant treatments around
the world
though not fully approved by the FDA yet
the treatment looks promising
about 85 90 of the time you deliver a
single infusion of stool into a
patient's colon and they'll beat the CF
infection that's really amazing
for one lucky Survivor of C diff Jen
Cooper this fecal transplant procedure
was her only hope
hi you tell me when you first got sick I
first got sick a few years back when I
had been hospitalized with gallbladder
infection which turned into a blood
infection so they put me on an extremely
strong antibiotics all the antibiotics I
had just killed all that good bacteria
in my tummy and finally got diagnosed
with c-diff what were your symptoms of
the C diff I'd go to the toilet 15 times
a day the exhaustion was just crippling
so so much fatigue I would spend days in
bed it messed with your head mess with
your body it was just it was a nightmare
so it really did like slip your life
upside down having this condition oh
absolutely you just get to a point where
you're so over it you just want help but
the fecal transplant had a tremendous
impact as beneficial bacteria kept the C
diff infection in check I feel like a
different person I feel years younger I
have energy it's above and beyond what I
thought it was
oh well I'm wishing you all the luck
scientists are now investigating whether
this treatment might work for other
conditions like obesity and autoimmune
disorders as well
novel medical approaches like this that
harness the power of a balanced
microbiome or forging the future to a
disease-free world
[Music]
full microbiome Replacements are
mainstream procedures to fight modern
diseases recipients first select from a
large catalog of ultra healthy donors in
the clinic patients microbiomes are
completely replaced with entirely new
microbial ecosystems once the
recalibrated microbiome takes hold
re-engineers the body itself prompting
healthier eating habits more desire for
physical activity and a heightened
mental state
[Music]
if there's one thing I've come to
realize it's that microbes can be as
much a source of good as they can be for
harm but to find our way to a
disease-free future the trick is getting
the balance and diversity just right
and it's not a straightforward path at
all
no one knows this better than Dr Jack
Gilbert whose own path of restoring the
healing power of microbial diversity has
been full of twists and turns
one very important reason Jack is
motivated to pursue this research is his
own son
I have a child with autism as soon as I
found out that my son might be slightly
different to other people I always
wanted to figure out a way that I could
help him
I don't think autism is a disease that
we need to fix but I did want to be able
to help him to realize his full
potential as any parent would about two
percent of children in the US are
diagnosed with autism
recent studies show that individuals
with autism have abnormal gut microbes
so Jack has been working on rebalancing
the microbial diversity of those with
autism including his son we actually
developed a dietary supplement to
improve his health so he eats a lot of
fiber now and he takes butyrate
supplements and Omega-3 supplements that
help him to regulate his behavior and
his health but Jack has found that the
most effective way to boost microbial
diversity is to boost Humanity's
interaction with non-sterile natural
environments
kids need physical interaction with the
environment physically interacting with
the world around them shapes how their
immune system works which can protect
them from Allergic Disease asthma maybe
even obesity and neurological diseases
like depression and anxiety we think
this might be fundamental to the process
by which a human body develops
I think that's the best recipe is let
kids play in the dirt and it's not just
natural environments that give this kind
of boost in the fight against modern
diseases exposure to animals can also
play an important role we published some
research which suggested that when
you've had dogs interacting with your
family it actually increased the amount
of microbial exposure children got and
it increased the degree of microbial
sharing between people
we know that children that grow up with
interacting physically interacting with
a dog under the age of one years old
when they're very young have a 13
reduction in the likelihood of
developing asthma it's huge right if
they grow interacting with a farm
environment there's almost a 50
reduction like in the developing aspect
to investigate this relationship between
microbial diversity and the natural
environment Jack spent time studying two
different communities that live on farms
most of which practice 19th century
agricultural ways of life
we started exploring two groups of
people in the United States called the
Amish and the Hutterites
they both live a very rural existence
where they don't really like technology
you know no no cameras no televisions
Etc
but they have one very specific
difference while both communities lead
Aurora lifestyle what are right children
don't interact with farm animals or
crops but the Amish children do the
Amish kids grow up milking cows and
working with the animals and we think
that the exposure they get to that
farming environment to the microbes in
the cows and in the sheep and in the
horses actually trains their immune
system the heart of kids are severed
from their interaction with the farm and
we see this reflected in their health as
a result hutterite kids don't require
the subsequent immunity training from
this exposure the arm is showing you
have about four percent asthma in their
population that's a half the US average
whereas the highlights have a
significant elevation in the disease
rate
with these dramatic findings Jack's lab
has been looking at ways that those of
us who live in more sterile Urban
environments can bring the microbial
diversity off the farm back to our
bodies and our microbiomes we've got one
strategy that we've been developing
we have living surface materials with
bacteria that we could place in a home
or a hospital even and enable that home
or hospital wall to have the beneficial
properties of say a farm
sounds a little bit science fictiony but
in the future we may be able to build
entire cities out of biologically alive
materials and maybe even spaceships we
work with NASA on trying to see if these
materials could be beneficial for
long-term spacecraft missions to Mars
for example oh amazing that is really
interesting
on my journey towards a disease-free
future it's become clear that Humanity's
relationship with our microbes is
complicated
I didn't realize the importance of the
human microbiome and how important it is
for our individual health
we need to balance the bad with the good
but we're running out of time
in an era of deforestation and
urbanization all over the globe the
struggle today is to preserve the
diversity of microbes that make up the
human microbiome before it's too late
but as a scientist I know to never
underestimate human creativity and
Innovation for Solutions in the future
what we want is really to understand
which are the microbes that are
essential what is their function and
then be able to use them as probiotics
so we are part of an initiative called
The microbiota Vault a joint project of
Gloria Rob Jack Martin and many others
The microbiota Vault will be like a
Nova's Ark for microbes microbiota Vault
it's a project that has long-term
storage
in a very isolated place to collect
microbial diversity from traditional
peoples and then be able in the future
to use them to restore our microbiome
because we know is going to disappear I
believe a vault like this may provide
one important key to the disease-free
world of the future
and armed by this arsenal of microbes we
evolved with Scientists will open up a
trove of new methods to fine-tune on
microbiome and improve the health of
everyone in the future I think
microbiome research is going to lead to
the possibility of having customized
microbiome therapy what we call
personalized Medicine by bio augmenting
our bodies with new microbes we can
train our immune system to attack cancer
we can alter the types of bacteria
living inside us to treat depression and
treat things like obesity and diabetes
that will have a fundamental impact on
how we deal with our modern day plagues
microbiome is going to revolutionize
medicine as for me my hopes for
medicinal applications hit a little
closer to home and it's inspired my
research in Neuroscience with any lock
microbiome therapy May one day provide a
remedy for Alzheimer's and other
diseases
but for the world as a whole My Hope Is
that the restoration of the microbiome
will not only boost the health of
everyone but lead people to happier and
more fulfilling lives
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]